yo it's the bootleg cab show james andre
jefferson junior everybody reel 923
la we got a special uh two guests with
us come on um fuel fest is going down
out here this weekend uh i actually been
to one field fest james i went to the
one in phoenix it was incredible
um
wow
that's what's up
yes sir
my artist alexis is actually performing
on saturday and he performed at the last
one so shout out to alexis cody walker
and tyreese
is on
with us how are you guys doing first of
all let's just start with fuel fest
and the idea and because it is a hell of
an experience like cody was this your
brainchild
yes it was i i love cars i love the
culture um a i'm a big car enthusiast i
love cars i'm i'm into the tuner cars uh
as my brother was um right like a lot of
people out there my age like
franchise is really what got me into
tuner cars um
you know i'm 15 years younger than my my
oldest brother who's paul
um
so uh it's it's cool it's it's like they
say do what you love
so i created fuel fest
it was called something else before it
was fuel fest and
tyrese and i grabbed some lunch over at
red lobster and yeah way talking about
it talking about this thing
and uh
hold on you got to tell them that the
first time you ever ate at red lobsters
when i invited you there bro you came
out first
that was your first time
like
i looked at this dude like
are you sure he's like yeah i've never
been here like i wanted to go like
this is the most legendary place of all
time
what was your favorite thing a red
lobster was it the biscuits
biscuits are good
um yeah baby we had a little bit of
everything
irish couldn't get over the fact that i
had never been to been there before
that's kind of why i wanted to make sure
that i formally
you know made the proper debut so i
ordered a bunch of [ __ ] that he couldn't
even eat he was just like dude okay
enough why aren't they sponsoring this
you have to know something for black
people some of the best decisions are
made of red lobster i married my woman
based off of dinner at red lobster so
y'all did something with that one
hey uh tyrese i see you got hookah on
the set over on the uh the new fast
movie i saw ludacris was clowning you
got the hookah set up on set what's
going on over there
wait
man you know what i mean we're gonna be
mentioning hookah let's go and get it
going baby so here we go right there
fuel fest okay let's go
my guys got the hookah hey so um
let's talk like obviously cody i you
know i saw um in arizona at fuel fest
you know uh obviously tyrese was there
vin diesel came out um you know
it's no secret that your brother uh you
know and those guys it was kind of like
a brotherhood it feels like the
fast and furious
family is very much so family i know
it's kind of cliche that is for family
thing
um but you know um it seems as they're
also embracing you as their brother as
well like um
you know obviously with your brother
passing uh that was what we're gonna say
tyrese
no no no i just wanna make sure that you
respectfully
you have to change the wording you gotta
remove the word kinda
no no
that's my brother
paul is my brother cody is my brother
cody was my brother caleb was my brother
before
paul ever passed like we are literally
brothers and i don't want to tell you
that the movie four brothers had
multi-racial you know people that are
playing brothers
but i'm telling you like it's not you
know i know you guys are kind of
brothers no no no no cody walker is my
brother
yeah cody walker's mom and paul's mom is
my mom and their father is my father
like we don't do this [ __ ] just for
shits and giggles for cameras you know
man it's very real so
like i love cody but cody could not
afford for me to go and show up to 10
fuel fest if i was in it for the money
like what can i do
to make sure that i use who i am and
what i am
as a family to make sure that we always
show up for each other and pour into
each other with anything that we're
doing
i love cody and i know money he got
money i got neither one of us could
afford to fly vin diesel in on a private
plane right show up to fuel fest in
arizona let alone what he would charge
to show up to some [ __ ] like that
we ain't got it so
this is like for real and what cody did
which i think is brilliant like him and
his brother discussed it in their own
way and he's like look not only am i
gonna keep the reach out worldwide
legacy alive
but everything about who my brother and
my family is tied into the car culture
which is the house that he grew up in
let's let's do something called fuel
fest
because even the fast and the furious
beyond is showing up in theaters of blue
ray and dvd
it's still limited in scope pertaining
to the actual car experience
so fuel fetch is an extension of what
the fans and the fast and the furious
can't get unless you show up to a movie
premiere right right i just wanted to
make sure i jumped in
you know i'm not defending cody i just
want to make sure that i do my part and
say like for anybody
who think that we are here doing this
for shits and giggles on camera i
actually talk to cody more often than
anything that we gotta do with business
you know i mean like we do this [ __ ] for
real it's family so go ahead yo what up
man we gotta stop the interview real
quick to tell you about our good folks
at blue chew that's right go to
bluetooth.com fellas
you know sometimes
you go through some stress you go
through a little anxiety and your dick
is not
performing maybe how you'd like it's
called ed a lot of guys go through ed
you could just be old as [ __ ] if you're
watching this and your dick ain't
working like it did when you were like
20. you know what i mean well listen
bluechu it is the wave uh how about this
the same active ingredients as viagra
and cialis getting delivered right to
your door in a chewable form in discrete
packaging and the best part about it is
it's all online
zero awkward visits to the doctor's
office zero you go online you sign up
with the promo code bootleg that's right
bootleg when you check out you will get
the first month for free all you got to
do is pay five dollars on shipping and
you're gonna get one month's supply of
blue chew all right and you're gonna be
[ __ ] like you were [ __ ] never
[ __ ] before
your dick's gonna
i'm gonna assume
you're adding at least a quarter of an
inch of erection that shit's gonna be
rocked up rocked up and socked up all
right boys so what you need to do one
more time go to bluetooth.com
and use that promo code bootleg and get
your first month for free
bootleg promo code bootleg on
bluechoo.com let's get back to the
interview
and cody i know you're around these guys
yeah that's i mean that's fair yeah
because how old were you when the first
fast movie was recorded because i was a
child when that movie i was in seventh
grade
makes sense yeah i was probably
i was probably knocking around i'm 35 so
i don't know how i drew our cody but 33
so we're around the same age when the
first one comes
he acts like a good white person
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i also know that there's a uh i remember
seeing that you have a charity uh that's
worked in uh obviously with fuel fest
man so kind of shed some light on that
cody yeah so it's called reach out
worldwide paul uh paul's the founder he
founded it back in 2010 after the
the huge earthquakes in haiti
and since and since then um
the organization is has been on like 80
80 some odd missions um spanning the u.s
and other parts of the world helping
people after natural disasters so
tornadoes hurricanes tsunamis
earthquakes
wildfires uh
you name it um you know that's that's
what the organization does it provides
medical aid and developing countries
uh helps people get back in their homes
here in the u.s
um we're actually doing a
a a bunch of rebuilds right now um
really cool opportunity came up for the
organization um they got a they got a
new show with the weather channel
um that we're actually in the middle of
filming right now this is our little
little break
but
we're rebuilding homes for people with
uh little to no insurance
that lost the everything in
tornadoes that sort of thing so that'll
be coming out in september um but yeah
fuel fest benefits uh reach out
worldwide we've raised
damn near two hundred thousand 000
at this point for the charity so it's
it's been awesome to be able to have so
much fun doing this i love this i get to
get all my boys out um we have a blast
and then also give back at the same time
so it's uh it's a blessing it's awesome
you got a great lineup uh the the so the
la fuel fest you got joyner lucas who's
[ __ ] on fire one of the best mc's in
the world obviously my boy simba
uh it's gonna be a crazy show but just
for people who don't know because like
it is a very
it's like a very vast experience like
you could go and not even know that
there's performances happening because
you're so wrapped up watching like drag
races or uh just looking at crazy ass
cars like what all
you know for people who haven't been to
field fest what all happened like
there's so much going on bro besides the
concert obviously yeah we call we we
call it a like a car and music festival
it's a celebrating car culture so it
doesn't matter if you're into tuner cars
classic cars
resto mod like whatever it's all there
at the show
but it's not just a car show it's
huge stage live music as you said joyner
lucas
simba is going to be on stage and at
irwindale speedway you know we call that
that's that's that's the house of drift
um we're going to be using the speedway
side we're going to have drifting going
on all day long professional
drifters uh as well as and we are in
california so we got to be clear
drifting in cars not not homeless people
not like drifters outside in north
hollywood yes drift singing thank you
there's a lot of drifters i got two of
them sleeping outside of my studio right
now you call them drifters i mean what
the hell is that in the 60s they may
have called them drifters anyway no no
no i think they call them squatters
squatters
no no no not squalor squatting squatters
yeah they're squatting
they go inside a an abandoned building
or a house that's not you know that has
nobody just like set up shop and just be
there or
or just the sidewalk no that's what i'm
currently doing i i don't play right
where i live i just squat
oh wow well you know when i come in town
you know i mean you send me that address
tomorrow i got you
bring the hoop
tyrese i'm curious how is uh the filming
going of the uh the new fast movie
obviously we saw a little bit of behind
the scenes with ludacris posting but how
is everything going man
everything is cool bro um you know they
kind of uh
this is different but
like
this fast and the furious is the first
one
where they've made us all like sign ndas
and
not me like showing anything or
like if i were to tell y'all who was on
the set yesterday
i would break the internet from
just even mentioning it so
couldn't take no pictures with them
couldn't take
couldn't do no videos behind the scene
like y'all welcome to the event like
it's like so in other words
will smith's going to be in the new
classic field oh come on everybody
congratulations
no sir i'm just i'm kidding i'm kidding
can you tell us this who's got the like
is it
the best trailer on set which trailer is
the trailer to be at is it yours is it
ludas
is it like vince who's got the most lit
trailer trailer
the two best trailers i've ever been in
or been to visit ever in my life is
actually owned by will smith and vin
diesel they got like
these three million dollar joints that
you gotta look up online to like see it
to believe it and
but yeah as far as
as far as trailers like
one of the things that i've always done
and cody will tell you this like what
paul walker's and brian's and and and
vendison's character do
with bringing everybody to that dinner
table in every movie that's kind of been
around from the beginning that's who i
am in real life
right yeah you know what i'm saying so
everybody
always ends up at my crib for all my
backyard parties and events
you know every time we do a movie or rap
a movie we always do wrap parties in my
backyard but that's when i had my crib
in l.a and i just sold it i was there
for 10 years but
like you know i'm i'm the guy that
proudly carries that torch like you know
in real life other than what we do in
the movie so
but yeah i can't tell y'all nothing um
i i will smith is not in the movie and
if he was i would probably just like
just don't say that but and he's the
biggest movie star in the world my big
bro forever come on now but yeah um we
just got
a level of star power and energy and
guest appearances
that's going to be crazier than anything
we've ever done and um
[Music]
yeah but i just want to tell y'all fuel
fest
which is happening in the next couple of
days saturday
saturday june 4th
june
no no thank you
it's okay
i'm trying to do a turn down service
we're live
yes so so um fuel fest is this saturday
and we want to make sure that y'all know
that the irwindale
raceway
is where fuel fest will be we're taking
over the entire
racetrack and the entire
you know uh function
period and and
it was also proudly
the racetrack that we started the entire
opening scene of fast nine in
oh that was back in time sequences
oh wow okay irwindale speedway
so
it's like coming full circle our first
ever fuel fest was la
and now to come back full circle and be
doing fuel fest again
it at the irwindale like everyone's
going to show up you know this is kind
of the energy online they like oh my god
we're about to go
to the racetrack where they like started
and opened the whole fast nine and now
to follow it and be doing fuel fest at
the same location
like this is probably it's already i
believe our biggest attendance and
energy
um but just make sure y'all go to
fuelfest.com
and don't be sleep at the will pun
intended and and make sure that y'all
get there
to to be a part of this moment you know
it's a great time
music energy
thank god
not even a child has ever fell and
scraped the knee at one of our events so
we've been very very blessed to like
bring
you know this culture and this
experience and even when then
showed up and surprised the whole world
in arizona he was walking around like a
big old kid and then he brought his kids
and put his son
in the car with a drifter
which is like you know like
yo here's my son
go show them what's really going on
because at this point when we do the
fast interference we can only do so much
driving before we have to pass it off to
the stunt drivers so when vin said to
his son who played him
in fast nine as baby dom
and then he got in the car with a
drifter a professional drifter it was in
the car like you know me
now
what what what cody what happened with
cody with paul walker has now happened
with with ben's son vincent
and he's now got his own car hey cody i
wanted to tell you this crazy
uh vincent
because of fuel fest
has now been building his first ever car
in his garage
oh wow i saw that i saw that i
we just put that up on instagram a
couple days ago and then ben was like
you see this car right here this is the
car that my son has been building
and we ain't done with it yet
but now the car that my son has been
rebuilding is now featured in fast 10
i'm like yo this is too much bruh oh no
he's taken too hard i got i got two
daughters so i don't really think my
daughter's gonna break a nail to be up
in there trying to figure out an engine
but
it's kind of crazy how it just continues
to stay
in the family and get passed on just
amongst us generation to generation
and um i almost look forward to having
my first son so that my son can get
active
in the fast family in any capacity i
mean what up y'all hey we got to stop
the interview to tell you about our
partners the presenting sponsor of the
bootleg head podcast our family at odd
socks man they're dropping so much heat
at odd socks right now go to
oddssoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg kev one word bootleg kev you
will save 20 off at checkout listen they
got the socks you know what i mean shout
out to the ninja turtles uh i totally
just dropped my
mic flag
and then they got the odd socks basics
which are just kind of like these boys
my favorites i love the odd socks basics
and let's not forget ladies and
gentlemen odd socks now has the
underwear that's right tapatio draws on
that ass
remember oddssoxofficial.com use that
promo code bootleg kev save 20 off at
checkout let's get back to the podcast
tyrese did you ever think um
you know way back in too fast too
furious that it we'd be to the 10th
movie and there'd be fuel fest and
there's you know you guys have a
national show that people go to that you
know just love the franchise and they
get a taste of it by going to fuel fest
did you ever have any idea they did get
to this point
listen man
asking me that question is just like
asking me to try and make sense of god
god doesn't make sense because he do
what he wants to do
and you know one of my favorite bible
scriptures is despise not small
beginnings
so
you may laugh at my chicken nugget but
in god's will it becomes a whole chicken
and then becomes a whole farm
so i don't think nobody from fast won
would ever even make the connection to
fast 2 let alone fast 10
and irregardless of what we're doing and
how long we've been doing it all of us
are in disbelief that the fans continue
to show up and show up on the level we
that they do
for us to release fast nine
and unlike every other movie studio out
there say
we're gonna lose our ass if we go
straight to theaters and not do
streaming and theaters and for us to be
the most profitable
movie release
during the pandemic because the fans
don't really want to experience fast and
furious unless they see it in the
theaters that took a lot of balls on
behalf of the studio
but it won
and ended up winning big because we're
like yo we've only served our meal this
way for 20 years right and why would we
go theater and streaming
when we know the fans are only used to
experiencing the fast interference this
way so we do not take the love for
granted
every time we start a fashion affairs
we're literally hugging each other on
the set looking around like oh my god
we still have an opportunity to do this
again it doesn't matter what we're
making the size of our trailers or the
box office receipts we're like oh my god
22 years ago paul
then because i wasn't in one i started
in two paul and jordana and the whole
crew
started this journey and here we are 22
years later now still dancing and now we
got fuel effects it's kind of crazy bro
yeah hey cody we're we're old he just he
just he just aged us 22 years later
man
hey i'm looking forward to fuel fest
i'll be there on on saturday uh people
can
people can get their tickets at what
fuelfest.com
grab them now they'll be more expensive
at the door bring the family it's a
family event
the whole family kids under 12 are free
this is a family event we want everyone
to be able to come out and have a good
time
um there's something for everybody kids
under 12 years old can get in free so if
you got six of them
are they about 12 and under
about 12.
daddy gotta pay but to six kids
including the kids in the stroller
open the door
let them in because they could be the
next star the fast and the furious they
just need to be exposed to the culture
and magic happens fuel fest there's
gonna be a lot of 16 year olds saying
they're 12 that day i'll tell you that
you know how you bro yeah i'm 12.
12.
you drove here bro
yeah you drove here bro you got a full
beard you are not 12. stop playing
that's a full baby
randomly before we get let you guys go
baby boys one of my favorite movies ever
has there been any talks of doing a
sequel or maybe some sort of spin-off on
baby boy
we'll talk about that in another
interview i'm not gonna say no
but i'm not gonna say yeah i'm not
willing to lie to you but okay i'll talk
about that in another take down
it hurts my feelings when you say that
but it's true if you don't get your
tickets online when you get to the door
it's going to be way more expensive
there it is from doorfest.com get your
tickets now get as many tickets as you
want and then cody do we still have any
slots left for people that had a cars
featured at the show or we sold out what
we did it is so tight we we are sold out
of certain certain ones uh there's
maybe a few left for regular car
registration but it's what's the
craziest car cody that you know is gonna
be there like just off the top of your
head what's the wildest car that we're
gonna probably see in your opinion
that's like asking me
oh man
that's impossible to say the reason why
is because morgan freeman is god
continue sorry
you're good i mean it just it depends on
like what what you mean by that if
you're talking about like expensive cars
expensive konigs eggs paganis you know
all that stuff three million four
million five million dollar cars those
will be there
there's a five million dollar car that's
crazy so my ford fusion hybrid 2017
won't qualify to be part of this right
you know oh for sure for sure though
that's the thing that's so great about
the show is we have super exotic
high-end stuff but we also
cater to the enthusiast crowd nobody
wants to see your ford fusion bro
too
everybody's out there
it's it's it's uh it's truly celebrating
like all of that stuff because that's
really my style
i i like the grassroots like i like the
the cheaper cars that you can mod the
crap out of like that's what that's what
i really love you know i'm a blue collar
guy you know what i mean it's like a lot
of those a lot of those super crazy cars
it's like that's not something that's
ever attainable for me like why would i
why would i
why in other words but bring your
tricked out dodge neon to fuel
a ford fusion hybrid 2017. no i don't
want to see that car
but
hold on
but you should bring the fusion you know
what i mean that's just not my personal
type of card for general parking
but i'm so glad you brought up the fact
that you drive a fusion so we've got a
pro drifter who's been a part of
multiple of our shows name's matt sopa
the dude has a ford fusion that he's
converted to rear wheel drive and he put
the coyote 5.0 liter v8 in it out of a
ford mustang and his whole the whole
reason for doing so is he wanted a
four-door
mustang so what's his name look it's the
most outrageous stuff but that's the
kind of stuff that i think shout out to
matt
that's his name matt
matt sopa
matt sofa's got a lot of [ __ ] time on
his hands ladies and gentlemen i'm not
going live
i have no idea what that meant
hey cody
can we can we do this live right now and
say that we're gonna let
let our brother right here ride and
drift in the car with matt because you
know they got the connection to the same
type of car even though his is tricked
out can we get you in the car with matt
to drift around can we get that done
let's do it i'm with it we'll be there
yeah we're there all right so with my
ford fusion you gotta we too grown to be
doing pinky promises but you got a pinky
promise there it is in the car with matt
we got it done come on now we appreciate
you guys for your time i know uh you're
over in the uk tyrese and uh cody we'll
see you this weekend
enjoy that hookah man wait wait wait
wait wait who said i wasn't gonna be
there bro i didn't i'll be more looking
i mean you i i'm trying to save some
surprises are you gonna be there
i mean that ain't none of your business
bro
all right i like how you came at him in
this ain't none of your business i mean
you don't but don't say i'm gonna be not
gonna be there though
yeah don't count me out bro it's called
an airplane bro hold on man
okay okay
we'll see what happens all right tyrese
cody appreciate you guys time hey man we
appreciate y'all for having us on a big
opportunity
fuelfest.com baby we'll see y'all there
on saturday god bless